- This video is brought to you by Keeps.
(mellow music)
What's up, guys?
Michael here to talk about how
a simple golden ring can
change a man's life forever.
Wow.
(dramatic music)
I'm not talking about marriage.
I'm talking about "The Lord of the Rings,"
and today in particular,
we're gonna take a philosophical gander
at our friends in the Shire.
But before we get into it,
I wanna tell you about this
video's sponsor, Keeps.
Did you know that two out of three men
will experience male-pattern baldness
in some form, by the time they're 35?
Keeps is here to help by making it easier,
and more affordable, to prevent hair loss
with their convenient
subscription service.
First, you get a free consultation
with a licensed Keeps doctor
who will choose which combination
of FDA-approved prescriptions
and over-the-counter
medications are right for you.
Now, throughout the process,
you'll be able to message
your Keeps doctor 24/7
to let them know how
your treatment is going.
And every three months,
your medication refills
will automatically land on your doorstep.
When it comes to hair
loss, prevention is key.
The treatments can typically
take four to six months
to start seeing results,
so get started today.
If you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss,
go to keeps.com/wisecrack
or click the link
in the description, to receive
50% off your first order.
That's keeps.com/wisecrack.
Now, back to the show.
Okay, I'm sure you've all seen
this movie a lot of times,
so, I'm gonna start right at the beginning
with something that I
think sets things up well.
(dramatic movie music playing)
Not a lot of movies where you see someone
kind of defeat the bad guy.
- [Lady Galadriel] But the hearts of men
are easily corrupted.
- Okay, so I like what it said
there, that the hearts of men
are easily corrupted,
and the ring of power
has a will of it's own.
Now, I think the idea here
that a ring, such as the
ring in the film, can reveal
the true nature of a
character, of a person.
And this is a huge idea that's explored
in Plato's "Republic". In particular,
book two of The Republic.
Where Socrates is talking
to a couple of dudes about
the nature of justice.
Now, the guy Socrates is
talking to, or Plato's brothers,
bring up the myth of "The Ring of Gyges".
And this ring is similar to
the ring we get in the movie,
right. The idea is that ya
get it, you go invisible,
and you can do whatever you
want. Now, in The Republic,
these two argued that the ring
is proof that no one really
has a desire for justice.
'Cause in the myth,
this guy gets the ring,
was a decent farmer.
But he puts it on, and he kills the king,
and he sleeps with his wife,
and becomes a really bad dude.
(screaming)
(dramatic music playing)
Let's jump ahead to see what happens
when Gandalf tries to get help
from his old mentor Saruman.
It's crazy to me that anyone
ever thought Saruman was like
a good guy, he, he's
clearly a very bad guy,
you can just see it when you look at him.
(door slamming)
(dramatic music playing)
Also it's funny that Gandalf thinks here,
that he's not gonna
close one of the doors.
That he'll find one that he
can't close. It's like, come on.
- You do not seriously think that a hobbit
could contend with the will of Saruman.
- There are none who can.
- Gandalf's reaction is like
when you realize that like,
your grandparent that you love
is actually kind of a racist.
I don't know.
- Friend, when did Saruman the wise
abandon reason for madness?
- And here, there's a
distinction between reason,
and madness. And I think
madness we can think of,
as a type of un-reason. Which
is more a passion or appetite
that's driving human behavior.
Okay, so in The Republic, Plato maps out
a tripartite account of the
soul. Which means three parts.
And the three parts are,
reason, spirit and appetite.
So reason, also called logic, or logos,
represents a philosophical
ruler in The Republic,
and this person values justice
and virtue above all else.
Its the justice focused rational faculty.
Now, justice occurs when
spirit works in accordance
with reason, and not in
the service of appetite.
Now in justice occurs when spirit
is in service of appetite.
When its pure desire
driving what the individual does.
Now here, Gandalf is saying
to Saruman that he's abandoned
the faculty of reason, or logic,
and instead is letting that
desire for power, That spirit
that's focused on appetite,
drive what he's doing.
Now in The Republic,
Plato describes reason as
being the smallest part
of these three elements.
But it's the most important,
because it unifies everything
else and drives it towards
justice. 'Cause without reason,
without logic, without that
desire towards justice,
people will just do whatever
the (beep) they want,
for the sake of their own desire.
I think we can see that
throughout this movie,
that sort of distinction between,
are people driven by
the part of their soul
that desires justice and reason, or by
that wants honor and fame,
or by the part of their soul
that just wants raw power,
and to feel good and
do whatever they want.
Oh, it's the first time
we see our fellowship,
- They must decide now, how to end it.
- The time of the elves is over,
my people are leaving these shores.
Who will you look to when we've gone?
- It is in men where
we must place our hope.
- It's really weird that
Gandalf believes in men so much,
but good for us, I guess.
- The race of men is
failing. The blood of Númenor
is all but spent. It's pride and dignity
- Elrond hates us though,
Elrond hates humans.
- It's because of men
that the Ring survives.
I was there Gandalf, I was there the day
the strength of men failed.
- Okay, so here, Elrond says that
the strength of men failed,
when Isildur did not destroy
the ring. Which would
benefit all of middle earth.
And instead, kept it for
himself to give himself power.
So, back to Plato's account
of the soul. This would be an
example of logic being
superseded by desire.
Isildur's appetite for power
was stronger than his desire for justice.
And Elrond thinks this
indicates a weakness
in the souls of humans overall,
but for Plato, it would
be that Isildur hadn't really
cultivated a love of justice
and reason. Right, he would
say that he lacks a properly
philosophical spirit, and because of this,
he would not be a good leader.
Now this comes up in The
Republic, where Socrates
brings up this paradox of
who would be an ideal ruler,
an ideal king. As the type of person
who actively wants to
rule, wants to be a king,
Socrates says, is the
opposite of the person
who should rule.
And then the person who should rule,
is often someone who
would not want to do that.
So, Plato's ideal ruler is a philosopher,
because he would be
focused wholly on justice
and nothing else.
- He's chosen exile.
- Okay, so obviously they're
talking about Aragorn.
When Elrond says "He's chosen
exile.", this is interesting,
and I think it applies to
what I just talked about.
With the account of philosopher
kings in The Republic,
and how people that want to be leaders
should not be leaders, people
who don't want to be leaders
are often the best suited.
And here, we're seeing Aragorn as someone
who has actively turned his
back on royalty, on leadership,
but because he's cultivated
a sense of justice and virtue
over and against a
desire for his own power.
- Gondor has no king.
Gondor needs no king.
- I can't help here but
think of Plato's Republic,
where the role of the king,
the philosopher king in
The Republic, is that
sense of reason and logic.
And I think when he says
that Gondor, and by proxy
obviously Boromier himself,
you know, needs no king,
it makes sense. 'Cause he's saying
it might not have that
sense of reason and justice,
and is driven by desire.
And that's basically what we
see when Boromier's arguing
that he should have the
ring to protect his people.
We got ourselves a Gollum.
- There's something--
- Frodo doesn't know they're
about to become great friends.
- Gollum has been following
us for three days.
Many that lived deserve death.
And some that died deserve life.
Can you give it to them Frodo?
- I think its interesting
because what's going on here,
is that Gandalf is acknowledging that
the goodness of ones soul isn't
some inherent fact. Right?
The desire for justice
orients one's soul in a way
that makes you a more just, and kind,
and happy, and virtuous
person. Orienting one's self
towards desire and injustice corrupts,
and destroys your soul. And
that's what happened with
Sméagol on the way to becoming
Gollum. Being oriented
towards straight up desire
leads him away from justice.
Makes him just a miserable little (beep).
And of course, we all know
this scene. He's just like
"Take the ring, I don't want it.
I don't want this responsibility."
- In place of a dark lord--
- And she just goes sicko
mode. Just total sicko mode.
Its very scary.
(dramatic music plays)
Looks evil as hell.
But, we got here and,
(dramatic music plays)
- I passed the test.
- Why does she say she's passed the test?
Well, right here, she had this
moment where she was tempted
by the power of the Ring.
But because her character,
her principles were virtuous,
she was able to not give in.
Even though by not accepting
the Ring it basically means
that the elves have to leave Middle Earth.
She knows that that's going
to affect her negatively.
But she refuses to let
the Ring corrupt her soul.
- You are a ring bearer--
- In this scene where she
says "You are a ring bearer",
it makes me think,
there's a famous episode
of the show "How I Met Your Mother",
where the character Barney
says he's gotten a ring bear,
and his friends all say "Did
you say bearer or bear?"
'Cause of where he was gonna
bring a bear to a wedding.
And I think, we can put the
clip in if I'm right here.
- We really do have a ring bear.
- What?
(audience laughing)
- Okay, jumping ahead of
it, (sighs) we all know.
This is a scene we all knew was coming,
where Boromier just couldn't,
- and you will beg for death,
- Couldn't hang on anymore.
- Fool! It is not yours
save by unhappy chance.
- (muttering) Scary, he's so much bigger.
- It should be mine! Give it to me!
(cringing)
- Give it!
- NO!
- Give me the Ring.
- No!
- Dang, invisible mode. And know too,
that Frodo does use the Ring,
but he uses it to get
out of hairy situations.
Okay, so after just almost getting robbed
and murdered by Boromier,
Frodo runs up to Aragorn.
- I would have gone with you to the end.
- This is important 'cause
again, he's tempted directly
with the power of the ring. But he shows
that he is virtuous in character.
His soul is being driven
by reason and logic,
which is oriented towards
justice, so he's able
to do the right thing, and its
not even that hard for him.
Compare that to Boromier
who is someone who's soul
is more driven by his appetites
and his desires for power.
Not driven by a rational faculty
that's focused on justice.
Its almost like Aragorn, in Plato's terms,
would make a good king. We'll see.
Okay, so unless you
thought I'd end this video
without getting Boromier's final moments
- My captain.
- We get a little bit of redemption.
- My king.
- Aragorn again showing,
he's just a real mess.
It's not that in his falling
to the temptation of the ring,
that it means that his
soul is just outright bad.
He screwed up. But we see him
dying with a sense of honor.
'Cause he recognizes that
temptation towards injustice.
He recognizes that his soul
is oriented towards desire
and power, more than it was
justice, which gets back to
that point once again, that
would be Plato's point.
That injustice can corrupt the soul.
Justice can sort of inform and
enliven and enrich the soul,
it's not just that ya
make one bad decision
and you're screwed forever.
Although, he is dead forever.
That's, ya know, he's
a human. And he's dead.
So he's dead now. But
he went down like a G,
so, what are ya gonna say?
Okay, so there ya have it.
By watching a great movie,
The Fellowship of the Ring,
we can learn a lot about
the nature of the soul,
and the nature of justice,
in Plato specifically.
I was talking a lot about
stuff that's in book two of
The Republic, so, read Plato's Republic
if you haven't already.
As always thank you so much
for watching. And thanks
to our patrons for all
that you do to support us.
Do check out our Patreon page
if you haven't in awhile,
we have a lot of cool new features there,
including a lot of extra
philosophical resources
if this is your sort of thing.
Also, check out our new
stream, Wisecrack live.
It happens right here every
Thursday at 11am Pacific.
Please, like this video if
you enjoyed it, subscribe,
ring that bell, all those sorts of things.
Um, and as always thank you
so much for watching. Later.
(upbeat music playing)